des dizaines de milliers de messages
sont en ligne il y a eu agression non
dénoncé puis mis tout l'été dernier une
autre vague de dénonciations des
violences sexuelles déferlait sur le web
depuis des années des victimes dénoncent
leur parcours douloureux à travers le
système de justice
ce sont plusieurs agressions qui se sont
produites entre l'âge de 4 ans et 11 ans
l'expérience avec le système de justice
c'était quelque chose d'assez
traumatisant d'assez marquant dans ma
vie lily thibeault a déjà raconté
publiquement son histoire moi je suis
rendu à prendre action pour que mes
enfants pour que les enfants des autres
ne vivent pas dans ce monde là que moi
j'ai connu je veux que les choses
changent et le changement pour elle
passe par la création d'un tribunal
spécialisé pour les crimes sexuels il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut faire pour
aider les survivants mais ça c'est
absolument aucune instance dédiée à
l'intérieur la chambre criminelle de la
cour du québec pour ces crimes le avec
des gens formés spécialisé un
accompagnement dédié et des aménagements
dans les manières de faire
appuyé par la députée véronique hivon
l'élite ibo lance aujourd'hui une
pétition pour que cette recommandation
phare du rapport d'expert rebâtir la
confiance déposée en décembre dernier
soit mise en place rapidement
moi je pense que c'est possible de
mettre en place un tribunal spécialisé
au cours de la prochaine année avant
donc la prochaine élection
s'il ya de la volonté de la volonté le
ministre je les barrettes assure qu'il y
en a vous connaissez lorsque j'entends
une priorité ça devient une priorité
sans toutefois fournir d'échéancier
précis l'objectif est de faire en sorte
de pouvoir mettre en place un tribunal
spécialisé dans les mères d'élèves c'est
ce à quoi on travaille mais dans le
monde juridique
il existe une certaine résistance j'ai
beaucoup d'hésitations avec un tribunal
spécial du c'est mieux accompagner les
victimes ou mieux informer les
intervenants aussi mais ce que cette
avocate créer ce sont les effets pervers
j'ai effectivement à part qu'on retrouve
plus
saint-hervé coupat est ce que vous savez
écouter jeu consciente que ce point du
côté très populaire en ce moment sauf
que ni très important qu'on ne le perde
pas de vue selon le dpcp l'an dernier
plus de 70 % des dossiers de violences
sexuelles ont mené à des accusations
issigeac audrey charbonneau raid au
canada mon frère